de dónde salen estas preocupaciones
sobre un eventual fracaso de la cuerda
hola que tal buenas tardes buenas noches
a todos como estan buenos y la realidad
es que hasta el día de ayer las
negociaciones parecían estar bastante
frenadas se había avanzado en algunos
avances de este tratado que como saben
tiene 34 partes importantes sobre todo
en el tema de áreas marinas protegidas
se ha avanzado bastante pero por otro
lado lo que estaba frenando el tratado
era todo lo que tiene que ver con
recursos marinos genéticos que es una
gran parte este tratado que se está aún
negociando en este momento pero la
realidad es que sabíamos que por parte
de muchas delegaciones había bastante
descontento porque las negociaciones no
estaban avanzando
y había muy poca flexibilidad por parte
de los países del norte global
en acordar sobre qué pasaría con los
recursos marinos genéticos una vez que
este tratado esté implementado pero hoy
realmente podemos ver que el sentido de
urgencia de poder terminar con este
tratado hoy como se había acordado luego
de dos semanas
realmente se asentó y podemos ver que
todas las negociaciones se están
trabajando muchísimo para poder
lograr en la plenaria que va a ocurrir
en una hora quizás poder votar un
tratado finalmente después de casi 20
años de trabajo y cinco rondas de
negociaciones a lo largo de seis años
ahora cuáles son las necesidades más
urgentes que deben abordarse para
proteger los océanos
bueno sin duda lo más importante para
avanzar en en relación a la protección
oceánica en este caso estamos hablando
de lo que llamamos aguas internacionales
que es un bien común de la humanidad que
son todas las aguas grandes porciones de
del océano que están más allá de las 200
millas es decir que son un bien de toda
la humanidad que hoy están totalmente
desprotegidas sólo el 1% de toda esa
porción de océanos que cubre casi el 50%
del planeta está protegido con lo cual
hoy lo más importante es poder tener
herramientas para crear santuarios
marinos o áreas marinas protegidas
estrictas en aguas internacionales para
poner límites a las industrias de
destructivas que han hecho realmente
estragos en los ecosistemas marinos y
permitir que estos ecosistemas se
recuperen eso hoy es lo más importante
y para eso para poder tener este
mecanismo esta herramienta legal que nos
permita crear una red de santuarios
marinos necesitamos este tratado global
de los océanos y necesitamos que sea lo
más robusto y sólido posible para que
esta red de santuarios marinos sea un
señora hueso ustedes han acuñado un
término llamado santuarios oceánicos a
qué se refieren con ellos y por qué son
importantes
claro es un poco lo que acaba de
comentar los santuarios sociales los
santuarios oceánicos son áreas marinas
protegidas estrictas es decir que son
porciones del océano que no se permite
que ocurran actividades destructivas o
extractivas en ese lugar y que
la idea es que sea una red que cubra el
30 por ciento de los océanos para el año
2030 eso es lo que los científicos
marinos
indican y recomiendan de cara a la
crisis ecológica y de biodiversidad que
estamos viviendo en este momento y bueno
es muy importante también que esa red
tenga relevancia y consiste es el
relance ecosistémica para poder proteger
estos ecosistemas cación desgastados
luego de años y años de explotación por
parte de las industrias